لم تكن اوكرانيا جزءا عاديا من الاتحاد
السوفيتي لم تكن خسارتها بعد انهيار
الاتحاد امرا مستوعبا لورثته
كانت اوكرانيا ذات الطبيعه السهليه مصدر
قلق لموسكو وتهديدا اوروبيا من الجهه
الغربيه في الاقتصاد موارد طبيعيه مغريه
استثمر فيها السوفيات كثيرا وانشئ بنيه
تحتيه صناعيه هائله كل هذه الخسائر
والتهديدات طفت الى سطح مره واحده عام
2014 ثوره شعبيه اوكرانيه خلعت الرئيس
المواليه لموسكو وسحبت البلاد نحو الغرب
الذي دعم الثوره البرتقاليه
الغربيه في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابقه
فقرر التحرك عمليات عسكريه في الجنوب
والشرق الاكرانيا مدعومه بتحركات داخليه
من موالي موسكو سيطره روسيا على شبه جزيره
القرم ومناطق من اقليم دونيسك سكانت
الامور على هذا الحال لسنوات وتحسنت
العلاقات الروسيه الغربيه اقتصاديا
وسياسيا عام 2021 بدات المطالبات
الاخرانيه بالانضمام الى حلف النيه الغربي
دقه موسكو ناقوس الخطر فذلك خط احمر لم
تقبل به وصول الحلف الغربي الى حدودها
الغربيه هو ما كانت تخشاه منذ انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي حشدت روسيا قواتها على
الحدود الشرقيه والشماليه لاوكرانيا او
اخر العام الماضي قالت انها مجرد مناورات
لا تهدف الى خوض حرب
في فبراير 2022 اعلن اقنيماني اوكرانيان
الانفصال من جانب واحد عن الاداره
المركزيه
الى جمهوريتين مستقلتين سرعان مع اعترفت
بهما موسكو مباشره طلبه الجمهوريه ثاني من
روسيا التدخل لما وصفته بالحمايه من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه اطلقت روسيا ما وصفته
بالعمليه العسكريه لمساعدته من وصفتهم
بحلفائها في الجمهوريتين الجديتين اطلقتك
ما وصفته بعمليتها الدفاعيه لاستعاده ما
وصفتها بالاراضي التاريخيه في الشهور
الاولى من القتال تقدمت القوات الروسيه
الى مشارف العاصمه الاوكرانيه وسيطرت على
مساحات واسعه الان بعد 10 شهور من الحرب
تراجعت القوات الروسيه ولم تقصد سيطرتها
الكامله على ما وصفتها بالجمهوريات
المستقله عن اوكرانيا خارج الحدود تقدماته
اكثر على الجهه الشرقيه زاد مساحه التماسي
مع روسيا دون السماحي لاوكرانيا بالانماء
تغيرت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في 10 شهور
ما لم يتغير طوال العقود الاربعه الماضيه
لا يزال القتال مستمرا بين الجنود والقاده
السياسيه